[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE.
I'VE ONLY BEEN EMPLOYED OF HER
TWO DAYS AND HAVE ALREADY PICKED
UP TWO REVERSE MORTGAGES.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL --
PROSTITUTES.
SO LET'S LOOK AT SOME HEADLINES
THAT I SAW TODAY.
TEXAS SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
CHANGED ITS RULES TO REQUIRE
STUDENTS TO USE BATHROOMS THAT
ALIGN WITH THEIR GENDER ASSIGNED
AT BIRTH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WHEN ONE STUDENT WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE RULING SHE SAID IT DOESN'T
AFFECT ME EITHER WAY.
I IDENTIFY AS A BEAR AND A LEAP
IN THE WOODS.
ACCORDING TO PROJECTIONS FROM
THE UNITED NATIONS THE
POPULATION OF THE PLANET HAS
OFFICIALLY HIT THE BILLIONS, BUT
DON'T WORRY, CHICAGO MAYOR OF
LORI LIGHTFOOT SAYS SHE IS
CONFIDENT SHE CAN DOUBLE THE
MURDER RATE.
[LAUGHTER]
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS BRACING
THIS WEEK FOR WHAT COULD BE THE
STRONGEST SANTA ANA WINDS OF THE
YEAR.
YOU KNOW, MAN, IT'S A GOOD THING
NO ONE IN L.A. LIVES IN A TENT.
[LAUGHTER]
MADONNA RECENTLY POSTED
REVEALING PHOTOS THAT SOME ARE
CALLING AND APPROPRIATE.
AND ONE PHOTO SHE WAS CLUTCHING
A BAG MADE BY BALENCIAGA AND
ANOTHER BAG MADE BY COLOSTOMY.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO A NEW SURVEY, 40%
OF CONSUMERS SAY AMAZON DELIVERY
DRIVERS ARE THE MOST ATTRACTIVE.
IN RESPONSE A JEALOUS UPS
WORKERS ARE PROMISING TO SHOW
MORRIS SKIN.
LET'S DO A MONOLOGUE, MIGHT GET
A LITTLE WEIRD BUT STAY WITH ME.
BUT TONIGHT AND WANT TO TALK
ABOUT DOGS.
AS I AM SURE YOU NOTE, I
RECENTLY GOT A DOG OF MY OWN.
YES, I GOT SICK OF STEALING
OTHER PEOPLE'S AT THE PARK.
HIS NAME IS GUS, AND UNLIKE THE
CAST OF "THE REVIEW WILL" HE
DOES NOT BITE PEOPLE WHEN HE IS
HUNGRY AND IS ALMOST
POTTY TRAINED.
AND UNLIKE JOE BIDEN HE DOES NOT
MARK HIS TERRITORY WITH URINE
AND CAN MAKE IT UPSTAIRS BY
HIMSELF.
TRUE, JOE IS JUST ANOTHER MAMMAL
THAT NEEDS TO BE WALKED.
BUT SINCE I GOT GUS I REALIZED
SOMETHING INTERESTING ABOUT DOGS
AS THEY RELATE TO POLITICS.
YOU SEE, I THINK DOGS ARE THE
GREAT UNIFIER.
AS MUCH AS CERTAIN LEADERS TRY
TO TEAR THIS COUNTRY APART,
SOMETIMES DOGS QUIETLY HELP KEEP
US TOGETHER.
OKAY, PELOSI IS VERY DIVISIVE,
BECAUSE SHE IS 90% PIT BULL, BUT
WE HAVE BEEN TOGETHER FOR 30,000
YEARS, YOU KNOW, WHEN PEOPLE
WERE BARELY CLOTHED AND SMELT
AWFUL, BUT ENOUGH ABOUT SETH
ROGEN.
SO DOGS MUST REALLY LIKE US.
THINK ABOUT IT, DOGS MIGHT BE
THE ONE THING PEOPLE FROM ALL
SIDES OF THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
CAN AGREE ON THAT THEY LOVE,
WELL, THAT AND PIZZA.
THERE ARE EVEN COMMUNISTS THAT
LOVE DOGS, BUT USUALLY ON PIZZA.
HEY, THE TRUTH HURTS.
AND REMEMBER DURING THE RIOTS OR
A CNN CALLED ED TO PEACEFUL
PROTESTS, THERE IS NO TORCHING
OF PET STORES WELL, ONE STORY,
BUT THE ANIMALS WERE SAVED BY
ONE DUDE.
>> LET'S GO!
[BARKING]
>> Greg: SO WHY IS THAT?
PART OF IT IS THAT PETS PROVIDE
THE PERFECT COMPANIONS WITH NONE
OF THE BAGGAGE.
DOGS ARE EASY TO UNDERSTAND,
THEY WANT FOOD, WALKS, PETTED,
IT'S LIKE A SPOUSE MINUS THE
COMPLAINING.
AND LIKE A SPOUSE, SOMETIMES
THEY BRING ME A DEAD BIRD BIRD
WHILE HER FRIEND MIGHT TALK YOUR
EAR OFF ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING,
YOUR CORGI WON'T BARK AT YOU
OVER THE GREEN NEW DEAL APPEARED
HE MIGHT ON YOUR LIVING ROOM
RUG, BUT JERRY NADLER WILL DO
BOTH.
BUT SOME DOGS CAN BE INTERESTED
IN POLITICS IF GIVEN THE RIGHT
MENTOR, HERE IS GUS WHEN HE
HEARS THE START OF TUCKER'S
SHOW.
IT >> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO YOU WAS TO BE 24, THE
FRUSTRATING THING ABOUT THE NEWS
MEDIA AND HOW HORRIBLE THEY ARE
IS THAT THEY NEED THEM COMING
YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND THE WORLD
EXCEPT THROUGH THE NEWS MEDIA.
>> Greg: BUT HERE IS GUS WHEN
HE HEARS BRIAN KILMEADE.
[SNORING]
♪ ♪
TO BE FAIR TO GUS, ALMOST
EVERYONE HAS THAT REACTION WHEN
THEY HEAR BRIAN KILMEADE SPEAK
INCLUDING CRACK ADDICTS.
I'M SURE THERE ARE SOME
INTERESTING PARALLELS BETWEEN
DOGS AND DEMOCRATS, WE KNOW THAT
DOGS LIKE SOME DEMS WILL HUMP
ANYTHING IF GIVEN THE CHANCE,
AND YES, SOME DOGS AND DEMS HAVE
FLEES, AND DOGS SOMETIMES FART
ON TV.
BUT FOR THE MOST PART DOGS
CREATE INFINITELY MORE LOVE IN
THE WORLD AND THEY DO PROBLEMS.
>> [LAUGHS]
AND IF YOU STILL DON'T BELIEVE
ME, ME, CAT, AND AOC ALL HAVE A
FRENCHY, A LIBERTARIAN, A NOT
BAG ALL HAVE THE SAME BREED, DO
I FEEL SORRY FOR AOC AS MUCH,
IMAGINE LISTENING TO THAT BARK
ALL DAY.
AND YOU CONSTANTLY HAVE TO CLEAN
UP AFTER HER.
AND NO OFFENSE TO CATS OR CAT
OWNERS OUT THERE, BUT YOUR PETS
HAVE A LOT GOING FOR THEM TOO,
BUT CRAPPING IN THE BOX AND ONE
OF THEM, AND IF YOU ARE A
PROFESSIONAL WRESTLER THAT OWNS
SOME TURTLES, THAT'S OKAY.
THAT GIANT TURTLES WOULD MAKE A
GREAT PET FOR NANCY PELOSI, THEY
BOTH LIVE FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
BUT JUST REMEMBER THE NEXT TIME
YOU ACCIDENTALLY SPILLED
PEANUT BUTTER, AND I'M NOT SURE
HOW YOU SPELL PEANUT BUTTER, BUT
IF YOU DO SOMEWHERE ON YOUR
BODY, YOUR CAT WON'T BE THERE TO
HELP GET IT OFF YOU!
BUT YOUR DOG OR MAYBE BRIAN
STELTER DEFINITELY WILL.
IF ANA NAVARRO DOES NOT BEAT HIM
TO IT.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
SHE IS BLOWN AWAY WHEN SHE
FORGETS TO FILL HER BACKPACK
WITH ROCKS, COHOST OF "AMERICA'S
NEWSROOM" AND "THE FIVE"
DANA PERINO.
AND OBSERVATIONS ON OUR CULTURE
GIVES THE LEFT AND ULCER, HOST
OF "TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT,"
TUCKER CARLSON.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SHE'S LIKE THE DAYTONA 500, LOUD
AND FULL OF SMOKE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND FLORIDA MAY HAVE THE LONGEST
COASTLINE, BUT TYRUS HAS THE
LONGEST CLOTHESLINE, MY SIDEKICK
AND TELEVISION CHAMPION!
SO FIRST OFF I HAVE TO GO TO
YOU, DANA, I HAVE TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE FOR MANY YEARS, MAYBE
TEN YEARS I HAVE BEEN MAKING FUN
OF YOU AND YOUR SILLY OBSESSION
WITH DOGS, YOU KNOW, WHETHER IT
WAS PERCY, OR JASPER, AND NOW I
REALIZE I AM A HYPOCRITE, AND
WANTED TO SHOW YOU BRIEFLY WHAT
I HAVE BECOME AND IT IS WORSE
THAN YOU.
[LAUGHS]
SILLY BOY.
YOU ARE SILLY BOY.
IT'S A SILLY BOY.
[LAUGHS]
THERE YOU GO.
SO, DANA.
I AM DISGUSTING.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO ME?
IS THIS A COLT?
>> Dana: IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
CULT.
IT IS A GIFT I BELIEVE FROM GOD,
DOGS FOR ALL OF US, AND ONCE YOU
GET IT, YOU GET IT, I ALWAYS
BELIEVE THAT YOU SECRETLY LIKED
JASPER, BUT MAYBE I DON'T
KNOW --
>> Greg: THE ONE THING I HAD A
PROBLEM WITH WAS WHEN HE IS ON
HIS HIND LEGS, HE IS TALLER THAN
ME.
>> Dana: AT THE DOG PARK, AND
ONE GREAT THING ABOUT NEW YORK
IS THAT CENTRAL PARK DOES ALLOW
DOGS TO HAVE FUN AND RUN
AROUND, AND I HAD A RULE, NO
POLITICS AT THE DOG PARK, SO
SOMEBODY SAYS, WHAT YOU THINK
IT'S GOING TO HAVE BEEN IN THE
ELECTION, OH, SORRY, I DON'T DO
THAT HERE.
WE JUST TALK ABOUT HER DOGS.
AND TO YOUR POINT, IT IS A GREAT
UNIFIER, AND A GOOD WAY TO START
A CONVERSATION AND A
CONVERSATION OR SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN ALWAYS FIND A SAFE SPACE
WITH YOUR DOGS.
>> Greg: VERY GOOD, TUCKER,
ARE ANY OF YOUR DOGS POLITICAL?
>> Tucker: NO, AND THAT'S WHY
I LIKE THEM.
THE BEAUTY OF DOGS AS THEY HAVE
NO MEMORY, NONE, AND THEY HOLD
NO GRUDGES, AND EVERYTHING IS
ALWAYS THRILLING.
EVERYTHING IS THE FIRST TIME.
MY DOGS, THE OLDEST IS 16, THE
YOUNGEST IS A YEAR AND A HALF,
THEY HAVE EATEN DOG FOOD
EVERYTHING WILL DAY.
>> Greg: YOU MEAN YOUR DOGS.
>> Tucker: MY DOGS, AND THEY
ARE THRILLED WHEN YOU GIVE THEM
DOG FOOD.
NOT ONE TIME IS IT LIKE DOG
FOOD?
THEY ARE LIKE DOG FOOD!
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
DOG FOOD!
THAT'S MY OLDEST, THAT'S MY
YOUNGEST, ALL SPANIELS, MY
HUNTING DOG.
I ADMIRE MY DOGS.
THEY HAVE REALLY BEAUTIFUL
SOULS.
>> Greg: YOUR DOG IS 16?
>> Tucker: OUR OLDEST MAKE IS
16.
>> Greg: THAT'S REALLY OLD FOR
A DOG.
>> Dana: HE TOOK GOOD CARE OF
HER.
>> Greg: THAT'S 112.
>> Tucker: SLEEPS ON THE BED
NEXT TO ME EVERY NIGHT.
>> Greg: SLEEPING WITH A
112-YEAR-OLD.
THAT MAKES TWO OF US.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ALL PAUL
PELOSI MOVE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE TERRIBLE, BUT
I HAD TO REPEAT IT IN CASE
ANYBODY MISSED IT.
SO, KAT, YOU HAVE A DOG MUCH,
YOUR DOG IS --
'S BE ON'S UNCLE.
>> Greg: IS THAT WEIRD?
>> Kat: YES, IT IS.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE ACCUSED MY DOG
OF SOME HORRIBLE THINGS.
YOU USED TO TELL LOVE CARL, NOW
YOU SAY THAT CARL IS A BAD
INFLUENCE ON GUS.
IT IS NOT A JOKE, HE DID NOT
WANT CARL TO COME OVER BECAUSE
HE WAS BEING A BAD INFLUENCE ON
HIS PUPPY.
A DOG.
MY DOG DOES NOT LIKE SMOKE
CIGARETTES.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
HE WAS HOPPING ON THE FURNITURE.
>> Kat: OH, SO WAS I.
[LAUGHTER]
STILL WEAR YOU.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
THERE WAS A LOT OF HOPPING GOING
ON.
BUT NO, AND THERE IS A CONFLICT
BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR DOG CARL
AND JEANS, YOUR CAT.
>> Kat: ALWAYS TRYING TO GET
CARL CANCELED.
HE KEEPS TRYING TO REPORT HIM
FOR DIFFERENT CRIMES, BUT
NOTHING EVER HAPPENS, BUT I JUST
TALKED TO THEM TODAY ACTUALLY,
NO HE SAYS HE IS GOING TO SAY
THAT CARL WAS AT JANUARY 6TH.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Kat: SO I HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT WHEN I GET HOME.
>> Greg: CARL -- IF A FRAT BOY
WAS A DOG.
>> Kat: YES THE FRAT-IST DOG
OF ALL TIME.
AND JEANS IS SO OLD AND FERAL
AND SICK AND I LOVE THEM SO
MUCH.
>> Greg: YES, YOU DO.
TYRUS, I HAVE ASKED YOU THIS
BEFORE, HOW MANY PETS DO YOU
HAVE?
>> Tyrus: I HAVE A ZOO, SO I
FIT IN JUST FINE IN FLORIDA.
A LOT OF EXOTIC ANIMALS AND OF
COURSE WE HAVE OUR YORKIE SUGAR
WHO IDENTIFIES AS A HUNTING
GERMAN SHEPHERD, AND I HAVE THE
BODIES OF PLENTY OF BIRDS AND
MOLES AND SQUIRRELS WHO JUST
THOUGHT THEY CAN MAKE IT.
AND MY DOBERMAN IS COMING
SATURDAY, SO I'M PRETTY EXCITED.
BUT I HAVE AN EXOTIC ZOO.
WHEN I WAS TOLD THAT YOU CANNOT
GO TO THE ZOO AND DO THOSE
THINGS, I JUST BUILT MY OWN.
SO I HAVE CHAMELEONS, TURTLES,
TALKING ABOUT TURTLES AGAIN,
SOMETHING IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
LIZARDS, I HAVE ABOUT 500
DIFFERENT SPECIES OF SICK LATES
THAT I BREATHE FOR FUN AND DON'T
SHARE, SO I HAVE A LOT.
YOU ARE SEEING SOME.
MY CHAMELEON AND THOSE ARE MY
TURTLES THAT YOU TRY TO MAKE FUN
OF.
AND COULD EASILY BE.
THAT IS MY GROSSLY OVERWEIGHT
THAT I OBVIOUSLY NEED TO WALK
MORE.
>> Greg: WHAT IS A TAGOO?
>> Tyrus: IT IS A LIZARD, THEY
ARE ABOUT AS SMART AS A CAT AND
HAVE 40 DIFFERENT SPECIES OF
PYTHON.
THAT'S MY ODD COUPLE.
PYTHON WITH A TREE FROG THAT GOT
IN THERE AND I ASSUMED IT WAS
THE TREE FROGS ASS, BUT TURNS
OUT THEY ARE BFFs.
I WAS LIKE THAT TREE FROG IS
STILL IN THERE.
AND THAT'S THE L